George Clooney and Julianne Moore hit  las vegas movie convention CinemaCon the  father to be directed the mom of two in  their upcoming movie suburbicon did you  give him any advice about children  because I don't know if he's fully  prepared that two are gonna come at once  I'm very very excited for him I think  there's nothing there's nothing better  than having a baby unless it's having to  so I think you have a great time George  and his wife Amal are expecting twins  later this year you fully digested that  that there's two coming no and I don't  know how you fully digest that but I'm  excited to be fun you guys have names  everything picked out my wife said I  can't name them casa and amigos that's  the one thing I'm not allowed to do what  you wanted to was justified yeah it's a  family business  [Music]